[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal guten abend
es war dann doch eine schwere geburt bis
sich die bundesländer heute endlich in
allen punkten einig wurden und mit der
bundeskanzlerin abstimmten wobei deren
macht in diesem gremium begrenzt ist
immerhin nach vielen stunden gibt es
beschlüsse und damit auch eine
vorausschau für die nächsten wochen
bevor wir diesen langen konferenztag
revue passieren lassen und darüber dann
auch mit dem chef des kanzleramtes
sprechen fast anna-maria schock kurz und
knapp zusammen auf welche konkreten
maßnahmen bürger und unternehmen sich
jetzt einzurichten haben
auch im dezember soll das öffentliche
leben in deutschland eingeschränkt
werden
bis mindestens 20 dezember bleiben etwa
restaurants und hotels zu staatshilfen
für die betroffenen betriebe werden
entsprechend verlängert und wie schon im
november sollen kitas und schulen aber
offen bleiben
neu ist dass die masken pflicht
erweitert wird so soll auch in
fußgängerzonen auf parkplätzen und
vorlesen einen mund nasen schutz
getragen werden und inhaber besonders
großer geschäfte müssen sicherstellen
dass sich in ihren läden nicht mehr als
ein kunde auf 20 quadratmetern aufhält
neu ist auch dass die kontakt regeln
weiter verschärft werden ab dem ersten
dezember sollen private treffen auf den
eigenen und einen weiteren haushalt
beschränkt werden
maximal sind fünf personen erlaubt
lockerungen soll es über die
weihnachtstage geben dann werden treffen
im engsten familien- oder freundeskreis
möglich sein
maximal mit zehn personen kinder bis 14
jahre sind hiervon übrigens ausgenommen
empfohlen wird vor weihnachten eine
mehrtägige selbst quarantäne möglich
etwa durch die bundesweit vorgezogenen
weihnachtsferien ab dem 19
dezember ein sowohl-als-auch also
einerseits verschärfungen andererseits
ausnahmen und lockerungen für die
festtag der eine oder andere in der
runde darunter die kanzlerin hätte sich
angesichts der aktuellen zahlen auch
noch deutlichere beschränkungen
vorstellen können mehr als 18.000 600
gemeldeten neuinfektionen heute also
wieder ein anstieg und 410 todesfälle
der bisher höchste wert seit beginn der
pandemie der teil shutdown hat
offenkundig noch nicht das gebracht was
erhofft wird wie die diskussion heute
verliefen wer welche bedenken oder
forderungen hatte
und warum das alles so lange dauert es
schreibt heike slansky dieses mal
sollten die gespräche nicht entgleiten
bloß nicht wieder zeit verlieren wie
beim letzten treffen ihrer ansicht nach
sind die infektionszahlen immer noch
viel zu hoch
de la merkel die malerin will nicht
lockerlassen 14 uhr heute nachmittag
vorfahrt am kanzleramt bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder
auch er zählt zu den strengeren dagegen
berlins regierender bürgermeister
michael müller
er musste nach der gescheiterten
konferenz vor knapp zehn tagen die
länder unter einen hut bringen
absprachen mit allen beteiligten für
diese video konferenz ein balance-akt
siebeneinhalb stunden später länger als
erwartet das zähe ringen um den
richtigen kurs ergebnis die
einschränkungen werden bis anfang januar
verlängert wir brauchen noch einmal eine
kraftanstrengung geduld solidarität
disziplin werden noch einmal auf eine
harte probe gestellt
vieles deutet darauf hin dass 2021 uns
erleichterung bringt und diese
hoffnungsvolle gedanke gerade im blick
auf die impfstoffe ist vielleicht etwas
was uns hilft schritt für schritt dann
die pandemie zu überwinden und bis dahin
noch die geduld die solidarität
aufzubringen dann muss es immer wieder
so sagen auch in vielen bereichen um
leben und tod geht es geht darum wie wir
menschen besser schützen können wir
haben große schritte nach vorne gemacht
im bereich der testung und des
impfstoffs aber es ist eben noch nicht
so dass wir damit in den nächsten tagen
so rechnen können dass das zu einer
entlastung führt die sehnsucht nach
einem lichtblick das weihnachtsfest als
verschnaufpause nicht konsequent so
viele kritiker die pandemie kenne keine
feiertage und silvester ist strittig
weihnachten ist das fest der familie
die liste mir das feste freundin wenn
man das so sagen darf dafür gibt es
ausnahmen was aber nicht heißt dass es
jetzt grenzenlose ausland es gibt nicht
darum silvester oder weihnachten die
große party zu feiern sondern vielleicht
auch an weihnachten einmal den wert von
familie zu schätzen
bloß keinen flickenteppich keinen virus
föderalismus klare und einfache
beschlüsse für jedermann nachvollziehbar
nur so lasse sich die akzeptanz und das
verständnis in der bevölkerung stärken
meint die opposition
namen sind vielfach unlogisch
insbesondere hätte ich mir gewünscht
dass im kulturbereich
doch darüber nachgedacht wird wie gerade
wenn es behördlich genehmigte hygiene
konzepte gibt wie man zu öffnungen
kommen kann in diesem bereich herrscht
vielfach alarmstufe rot
es ist völlig offen unter welchen
bedingungen überhaupt in den nächsten
wochen vielleicht sogar monate wie der
gesellschaftliches kulturelles und
wirtschaftliches leben stattfinden kann
deshalb ist unverändert unsere position
dass wir über eine alternative corona
strategie sprechen müssen morgen im
bundestag regierungserklärung zur corona
pandemie angela merkel will den kurs von
bund und ländern bis zum jahresende
erklären
viele themen über die wollen wir mit dem
chef des kanzleramtes mit frau merkels
rechte hand gewissermaßen helge braun
sprechen guten abend herr braun
einen schönen guten abend ja sie haben
das mit vorbereitet waren bei diesen
stundenlangen gesprächen mit dabei
gucken wir uns ein paar der punkte mal
einzeln an also wenn ich das richtig
sehe weihnachten und silvester können
sich zehn leute aus zehn haushalten
treffen und über die tage gestreckt auf
jeden tag mit zehn anderen ist es das
was man im kanzleramt epidemiologisch
vernünftig fand das ist aber sehr
voraussetzungen es reich wir haben sehr
dafür geworben und das ist auch im
beschluss jetzt drin dass familien die
gerade ältere und und wohlhabende
menschen treffen wollen vor weihnachten
eine woche zeit bekommen eine sogenannte
schutz woche wo man wirklich seine
kontakte am besten auf ein minimum
reduziert im familienverband bleibt und
damit sicher stellt dass man sich nicht
angesteckt hat kurz vor weihnachten aber
da muss man sagen mit gutem gewissen zu
den großeltern ging aber gibt's die denn
jetzt diese woche wir haben ja jetzt
einheitlich festgelegt dass die
weihnachtsferien sozusagen mit dem
letzten schultag am freitag dem 18
beginnen sollen zwei bundesländer sind
sich da noch nicht so sicher aber im
großen und ganzen sind die dazu bereit
das heißt je nachdem wann man an den
weihnachtsfeiertagen die große eltern
trifft sind fünf bis sieben tage möglich
aber erst treffen sich jetzt nicht nur
die großeltern sondern zehn leute aus
den haushalten das
schon auch viel und wir reden ja auch
über silvester also war das nochmal das
eine aber silvester da sagte auch herr
söder immer da geht es eigentlich um
party und freunde da gibts noch ein
relativ wenig beschränkungen ja deshalb
haben wir auch gesagt diese zweite
möglichkeit weil wir jetzt nicht leute
in die verdrückungen bringen wollten zu
sagen dass irgendwie onkel karl jetzt
nicht mit weihnachten feiern kann
sondern sich gut vorbereiten auf
weihnachten vorher vorsichtig sein sich
dann ruhig im familienkreis treffen
darauf achten dass niemand symptome hat
sondern im zweifelsfall einen test
machen
das soll für weihnachten gelten
längstens bis zum ersten ersten auch da
soll es eher um die weihnachtsfeiern
gehen und nicht darum dass es dann
ausgelassene silvester feiern gibt es
werden einige bundesländer vermutlich
die regelung auch schon vor dem 31 12
wieder beenden
naja nun bleibt es bei dieser incidents
von 50 auf 100000 sozusagen als unser
aller kollektives ziel ist das
realistisch dass sich das in den
nächsten wochen überhaupt noch erreichen
weiß dass man das so weit wieder
herunter bekommt also wenn man die
länder sich anguckt um uns herum die
wirklich ein ganz schlimmes
infektionsgeschehen hatten weit mehr als
bei uns belgien oder tschechien da sind
länder dabei die es wirklich geschafft
haben in kürzester zeit die zahlen auch
wieder sehr deutlich zu senken
das setzt natürlich voraus dass man da
wo das große infektionsgeschehen
stattfindet das auch deutlich reduziert
und insofern ist das keineswegs
ausgeschlossen
wir müssen entschlossen handeln und
deshalb kamen ja diese woche auch der
appell gerade an die jüngere bevölkerung
wo die residenzen sehr sehr hoch sind
dass man kontakte reduziert und wir
haben ja schon einen teil des weges
geschafft wir haben ja schon dass es das
wachstum gebrochen und jetzt muss es
nicht zur seite sondern runtergehen
auf appelle wird wirklich so gehört wie
sich die politik das wünscht der weil er
unser privatbereich der der ansteckung
bereich ist er am bedeutendsten ist
kommt auf appelle und auf die mitwirkung
der bevölkerung sehr an
selbst wenn wir sozusagen in der
wirtschaft an ganz vielen stellen
beschränkungen machen
am ende ist der haupt ansteckung bereich
der private bereich und deshalb ist
diese dieser hinweis auch wenn man
freunde trifft dann wirklich diese
abstandsregeln die hygieneregeln
einzuhalten ganz ganz wichtig und haben
sogar gesehen dass die leute das gemacht
haben bevor unsere beschränkungen
gegriffen haben anfang november also
wenn die leute mitziehen und das tun ja
den allermeisten wofür wir sehr dankbar
sind dann können wir auch die zahlen
senken
aber brauchen sie sagten auch gerade das
hauptthema ist das privatleben aber die
leute sind zum beispiel auch wie die
sardinen büchsen in der s-bahn wenn sie
auf dem weg zur arbeit sind und nicht
jedes büro oder jeder auch kleineres
unternehmen wo es kein publikumsverkehr
hält sich jetzt wirklich an diese masken
und abstandsregeln müsste man nicht dann
in dem bereich auch mal mehr gucken als
die leute immer nur in ihre freizeit um
privatbereich sozusagen einzuschränken
ja absolut deshalb haben wir ja auch
nicht nur bußgelder sondern auch
verstärkte kontrollen verein war gibt
auch jetzt wieder angehen unternehmen zb
die leute ins home office nach
möglichkeit zu schicken es ist eine
bitte ist es keine vorschrift wir können
auch nicht alles vorschreiben wann home
office möglich ist und dann nicht das
müssen schon in den unternehmen
arbeitnehmer und arbeitgeber gemeinsam
entscheiden
aber wir haben auch zum beispiel jetzt
etwas gemacht dass wir heute sonst sehr
mit der deutschen bahn beschäftigt haben
besonders lange sitzt man ja im
fernverkehr möglicherweise neben
jemandem der infiziert ist und deshalb
nochmal ein ausgeklügeltes
reservierungssystem das nach möglichkeit
der nachbar platz wirklich frei bleibt
da sind wir heute auch noch mal ein
großen schritt weiter gegangen
das soll jetzt also auch geben da hätte
ich sonst auch noch nachgefragt ein
großes thema und auch ein umstrittenes
thema schulen warum erst ab einer
inzidenz von 200 in möglichen hybrid und
vorrechte hat er sich die
bundeskanzlerin ja eigentlich auch
deutlich mehr gewünscht
ja also das ist kein geheimnis dass wir
eigentlich uns gewünscht hätten dass bei
einer deutlich niedrigeren incidents
schon zu machen
aber im grundsatz ist es jetzt mal
wichtig dass wir deutlich machen
gerade ab der achten klasse das sind die
jahrgänge in der schule wo auch wir
sehen dass die die zeile infektion sehr
hoch ist
häufig sind die jungen leute dann nicht
besonders schwer krank aber sie tragen
eben die infektion weiter und deshalb
zusagen halte abstand im privatleben
aber in der schule ist es nicht so das
ist auch irgendwie nicht nach
vollziehbar und deshalb gerade da wo
besonders viele infektionen sind müssen
alle regeln abstand hygieneregeln masken
tragen und lüften zusammenkommen um die
infektionsgefahr in der schule möglichst
stark zu reduzieren aber eben auch erst
ab 200 und nicht zum beispiel schon ab
was mich auch interessiert es gibt nach
wie vor keine einheitlichen quarantäne
regeln wenn es einen positiven schüler
schülerin in einer klasse zum beispiel
gibt es geht dann zum teil nach
gutdünken die einen sagen auch na ja da
muss auch der sitznachbar nach hause die
anderen sagen auch alle anderen kinder
dürfen weiter zur schule wieder andere
schuldirektoren sagen ach dann geht die
ganze klasse in quarantäne
da gibt es immer noch keine einheitliche
regelung das bestimmt immer noch das
lokale gesundheitsamt und die
schulleitung oder haben sie da etwas
geändert also grundsätzlich gibt es dann
natürlich vom lokalen gesundheitsamt
eine verantwortung wir haben aber heute
genau dazu etwas vereinbart nämlich die
sogenannte cluster strategie zu
verfolgen
da geht es darum dass wenn ein positiver
fall in einer schulklasse auftaucht dass
dann die ganze klasse sofort in
quarantäne geht nach hause
dass wir aber dadurch dass wir jetzt
schnell tests haben schon nach fünf
tagen alle testen und wer dann negativ
ist kann wieder zurück in den unterricht
dh dass es eine sehr viel schnellere
einfachere und vergleichbar effektive
maßnahme wie eine kontakt nachverfolgung
jedes einzelnen kontakt erster und
zweiter ordnung also einfacher schneller
und genauso effektiv definitiv ein thema
das sehr viele zuschauern zuschauern
interessiert das thema schulen
verbrauchen danke für das gespräch sehr
gern
das interview mit dem kanzleramtschef
haben wir direkt im anschluss an die
pressekonferenz vor gut einer stunde
geführt
unabhängig davon wie es an den schulen
in den nächsten wochen und monaten
weitergeht eines ist wohl klar
es wäre unrealistisch anzunehmen dass es
dann irgendwo abstriche geben wird beim
unterrichtsstoff schon nach dem lockdown
im frühjahr klagten lehrer und eltern ja
darüber dass viele kinder während des
homeschooling es eine menge versorgt
haben
und so wird jetzt die forderung immer
lauter an die lehrpläne ranzugehen sie
zu entschlacken
klingt ja erstmal ganz logisch und auch
nicht so schlimm aber wer sich jemals
beruflich mit dem erstellen von
lehrplänen beschäftigt hat weiß das wird
schwierig dort ferber berichtet die
masken im unterricht sie sind das
kleinere problem an diesem hirner
gymnasium das größere die hohe
intelligenz
sie haben hier erfahrung mit quarantäne
und distanz unterricht also ich glaube
man arbeitet in der mittelstufe
sicherlich verlangsamter dann man kriegt
das ganze curriculum nicht mehr so
geschafft dann fällt halt irgendwas aus
man muss das nacharbeiten und sozusagen
das end pensum wird nicht in dem
zeitraum hundertprozentig geschafft es
sind zeiten in denen lüftungs pausen und
online unterricht neue normalität sind
und schulleitungen zweifeln dass so der
lehrplan zu schaffen ist
es kann gar nicht so unterricht gemacht
werden wie es normalerweise gewohnt ist
und das muss man einfach in rechnung
stellen dass viele schulen ja immer
automatisch 25 vielleicht ein drittel
weniger unterrichtszeit zur verfügung
stellt was aber soll was darf wegfallen
statistik in mathe textanalyse in
englisch oder demokratie kunde und nicht
alle lernen alles zur selben zeit auch
das ein problem
der stoff muss gekürzt werden allerdings
nicht jetzt während des schuljahres für
dieses schuljahr weil dann laufen wir
gefahr schüler in inhalte zu kurz zu
kürzen die sie bereits behandelt haben
und dann lösen wir einfach nur noch mehr
panik aus obwohl wir den menschen helfen
wollen
es ist die sorge um das abitur 2021 und
überhaupt niemand der im nächsten jahr
einen abschluss macht solle
benachteiligt werden sagt die
schulpolitik mehr sagt sie auch nicht
wir werden natürlich entsprechend für
dieses schuljahr weiter gucken ob wir
anpassungen vornehmen müssten und uns
sagen übrigen auch die bildungs
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dass die zeit jetzt es von corona die
achteinhalb monate in denen wir jetzt in
dieser sondersituation leben sich auf
die weitere schullaufbahn nicht stark
auswirken
in den schulen fürchten viele genau dass
es fehle stoff aus dem vergangenen
schuljahr und jetzt gehe es eben nicht
normal weiter und auch eltern ärgern
sich über das weiter so bei den
lehrinhalten in pandemie zeiten die
politik vermeidet darüber konkret zu
sprechen
offiziell heißt es immer noch die kern
der pläne sollen so bearbeitet werden
wie mal gedacht und das ist unseres
erachtens einfach unrealistisch der
schulstoff in corona ja er bleibt
umstritten und ein große herausforderung
viele hintergrundinformationen zu corona
finden sie bei uns immer auch online auf
zdf heute.de und natürlich können sie
dort auch die heute abend beschlossenen
maßnahmen im einzelnen noch mal
nachlesen
und jetzt macht erstmal kaiser der
richter weiter mit anderen nachrichten
die bundesregierung will verstärkt gegen
rechtsextremismus und rassismus vorgehen
mit fast 90 maßnahmen
darauf hat sich der kabinettsausschuss
geeinigt der nach den rassistischen
morden von hanno gegründet worden war
so sollen sogenannte feindes listen
unter strafe gestellt werden mit denen
öffentlich politische gegner bedroht
werden
außerdem ist ein neuer straftatbestand
für antisemitische oder rassistische
hetze geplant für direkte angriffe die
nicht als volksverhetzung gelten und wie
wichtig das thema ist zeigen auch
alarmierende zahlen des londoner
instituts für wirtschaft und frieden
demnach ist die bedrohung durch
rechtsextreme gewalt so hoch wie seit 50
jahren nicht mehr
seit 2014 habe die zahl entsprechender
vorfälle in europa nordamerika und
ozeanien um 250 prozent zugenommen
allein im vergangenen jahr seien dort 89
menschen von rechtsextremisten getötet
worden
betrachtet man weltweite alle
terroranschläge zusammen gegen die zahl
der todesopfer 2009 10 um 15 prozent
zurück auf fast 14.000 bundeswehr
soldaten die wegen ihrer homosexualität
diskriminiert wurden sollen eine
entschädigung erhalten
einen entsprechenden gesetzentwurf hat
das kabinett auf den weg gebracht
demnach erhalten betroffene 3000
euro wenn sie wegen ihrer sexuellen
orientierung entlassen nicht befördert
oder verurteilt wurden das gleiche gilt
für einige soldaten der nationalen
volksarmee
erst im jahr 2000 hatte die rechtliche
diskriminierung in der bundeswehr ein
ende nach einer verfassungsbeschwerde
us-präsident trump hat seinen früheren
nationalen sicherheitsberater michael
flynn begnadigt das teilte er vor
wenigen minuten auf twitter mit
flynn hatte sich schuldig bekannt das
fbi belogen zu haben über seine kontakte
zum früheren russischen botschafter in
den usa bei den damaligen ermittlungen
ging es um eine mögliche einflussnahme
russlands auf die us-präsidentenwahl
2016 später zur flinders
schuldbekenntnis zurück der zuständige
richter setzte das verfahren aber
zunächst trotzdem fort trump hatte sich
mehrfach darüber beklagt dass flitton
von der justiz verfolgt werde
thüringens ministerpräsident ramelow
muss damit rechnen dass seine immunität
aufgehoben wird
einen entsprechenden antrag hat die
staatsanwaltschaft erfurt gestellt
darüber entscheiden muss der
justizausschuss des thüringer landtags
dessen vorsitzender der afg abgeordnete
stefan müller hatte gegen ramelow
anzeige erstattet wegen beleidigung
hintergrund ist ein vorfall von mitte
juli ramelow hatte müller im landtag den
mittelfinger gezeigt und ihn als
widerlichen drecksack bezeichnet mit dem
deutschen zukunftspreis er der
bundespräsident herausragende
innovationen die unsere welt ein
bisschen besser machen dieses jahr geht
er an ein forscherteam aus baden
württemberg und thüringen die
preisträger arbeiten an neuen methoden
mit denen sich immer kleinere und
leistungsfähigere mikrochips erstellen
lassen
zb für smartphones oder roboter dafür
nutzen sie unter anderem lasertechnik
das zdf zeigt die preisverleihung direkt
nach dem heute schon die korona pandemie
und der regierungswechsel im weißen haus
sind so große aktuelle welt themen das
anderes schnell aus dem blick gerät
dabei spielen sich daneben ja auch noch
andere dramen ab in weltregionen in die
wir von unseren breitengraden aus
sowieso nicht allzu oft blicken
das gilt etwa für die kaukasusregion
berg karabach die erst durch den
kriegsausbruch dort wieder in den fokus
rückte ein blutiger krieg der über
wochen tobte und am ende einen
militärischen sieger hat als aber john
hat grosse gebiete erobert
beziehungsweise aus seiner sicht
zurückerobert dies nachdem vor zwei
wochen getroffenen
waffenstillstandsabkommen auch behalten
darf als er bei ghana kehren nun in
gebiete zurück aus denen arminia fliehen
in den 90er jahren beim letzten krieg um
berg karabach war es umgekehrt
das nun frieden einkehrt ist aber leider
nicht zu erwarten ist für uns den berg
karabach und beobachtet die alte wunden
neu aufgerissen werden auch jetzt
während des waffenstillstands hat karen
seine kalaschnikow immer griffbereit
für den fall dass er zurück an die front
gerufen wird drei kriege gegen
aserbaidschan hat der 58 jährige schon
gekämpft
dieser war anders im ersten krieg haben
wir hauptsächlich mit unseren gewähren
gekämpft aber jetzt ist diese waffe
quasi nutzlos
sie haben viel artillerie eingesetzt und
drohnen damit haben sie uns große
verluste beschert hand hat an der seite
seines vaters gekämpft jeder in
bergkarabach kenne jemanden dem krieg
gestorben sei erzählt er uns zwei wochen
nach seinem kriegseinsatz scheint der
junge arminia jede hoffnung auf eine
friedliche zukunft verloren zu haben
ich kann in dieser sache einfach nicht
optimistisch sein
ich glaube niemandem und ich glaube
nicht dass dieser waffenstillstand
halten wird teil des
waffenstillstandsabkommens ist dass
armenien große gebiete die es seit mehr
als 25 jahren kontrollierte an
aserbaidschan zurückgibt bevor es soweit
ist zünden viele arminia ihre häuser an
nichts als verbrannte erde soll dem
feind überlassen werden petros nimmt
alles mit womit er und seine verwandten
sich ein neues zuhause bauen können
irgendwo auf armenischen land die
normalen leute wollten all das nicht das
war ein krieg der könige es ging dabei
nur um ihre eigenen interessen
weder die menschen aserbaidschan noch
die armenier wollten diesen krieg ferne
mächte mischen mit die türkei an der
seite aserbaidschans und russland das
erst den waffenstillstand mit
verhandelte und dessen soldaten jetzt
die neuen grenzen zwischen den
verfeindeten nachbarn sichern sollen
fast jeder mit dem wir hier in den
letzten tagen in bergkarabach gesprochen
haben hat seine dankbarkeit russland
gegenüber zum ausdruck gebracht moskau
habe den krieg beendet heißt es dann
dass präsident putin dabei auch seine
eigenen interessen verfolgt hat und die
militärische präsenz russlands im
südkaukasus ausgebaut hat das stört die
arminia wenig in dem teil berg karabach
der unter armenischer kontrolle bleibt
hat der wiederaufbau begonnen
dächer werden repariert schutt
weggeräumt und eine große sorge geteilt
dass der frieden zwischen armenien und
aserbaidschan womöglich nicht von dauer
sein könnte
und jetzt nochmal kaiser eine gerechtere
besteuerung großer internetkonzerne das
fordern viele doch eine internationale
lösung ist vorerst nicht in sicht
nun hat frankreich im alleingang eine
digital steuer eingeführt die
betroffenen unternehmen hätten die
bescheide bereits erhalten bestätigte
das finanzministerium
washington hatte paris mit strafzöllen
gedroht sollte frankreich die steuer
einführen
sie trifft vor allem große us konzerne
amazon google oder facebook viele züge
der deutschen bahn sind seit beginn der
korona pandemie deutlich leerer als
sonst bei viele kunden lieber mit dem
auto fahren oder lieber gar nicht reisen
nun soll die bahn für mehr abstand
sorgen was die bahn sicherer machen
dürfte frank bethmann aber auch ärmer
dabei ist schon jetzt die rede von einem
rekorddefizit ja was deutlich über fünf
milliarden euro liegen dürfte denn schon
das halbjahres defizit lag ja pandemie
bedingt bei 3,7 milliarden euro und an
der schwachen auslastung hat sich ja
nichts geändert die fernzüge sind
zurzeit nur noch zu 20 prozent
ausgelastet die regionalzüge zu 55 bis
60 prozent trotz leerer abteile will die
bahn am regulären fahrplan festhalten
sogar noch mehr züge einsetzen für noch
bessere abstands möglichkeiten wie wir
es aus den ergebnissen der heutigen bund
länder konferenz ja schon gehört haben
die verluste drohen dadurch weiter zu
wachsen die eigentlich der bund
ausgleichen will
doch es könnte sein dass die eu
kommission nur einen teil der 5
milliarden spritze zulässt denn nicht
alle probleme seien auf corona
zurückzuführen im güterverkehr laufen
die verluste bereits seit jahren auf die
allianz pro schiene macht dafür aber
nicht die bahn selbst sondern den bund
verantwortlich der verband prangerte
heute erneut jahrelange
fehlentwicklungen zu lasten der china an
vor allem seien die jüngsten kaufprämien
für lkw falsch für güter loks gebe es
dagegen keine zuschüsse
zudem wird diesel subventioniert und es
fehlen gleisanschlüsse für
gewerbegebiete auf diese weise warnt die
allianz pro schiene werde das ziel bis
20 30 25 prozent des güterverkehrs auf
die schiene zu verlagern
klar verfehlt schlecht auch für die
umwelt danke an die börse frank zwei
deutsche klubs mussten heute in der
fußball champions league ran bayern und
gladbach und beide haben ihre partie
gewonnen
die bayern eben gerade gegen salzburg
mit 3 zu 1 damit stehen sie im
achtelfinale
borussen haben das tor zum achtelfinale
immerhin weit aufgestoßen
mit einem 14 0 gegen schachtjor donezk
die treffer erzielten kapitän lars
stindl per foulelfmeter
nico i bdm bono mit einem fallrückzieher
und per freistoß ein kurzer blick auf
die lottozahlen wie immer ohne gewähr
10 11 16 17 18 30 superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie im zdf
text und auf lotto zdf de der gott des
fußballs hat seinen berühmtesten
stellvertreter auf erden wieder zu sich
geholt diego maradona die krone des
weltfußballs selbsternannte hand gottes
ist tot er starb im alter von nur 60
jahren gesundheitliche probleme hatte er
viele und auch schon lange erst kürzlich
hatte er sich einer operation
unterziehen müssen nach auskunft seines
anwalts ist maradona nun an herzversagen
gestorben das wiederum bricht fans in
aller welt das herz kaum ein anderer
fußball star wurde auch lange nach
seiner aktiven zeit noch so frenetisch
pocket hat und sorgte immer wieder für
so viele schlagzeilen als stünde er
immer noch auf dem platz
dort war er zweifellos der beste oder
zumindest einer der besten fußballer
aller zeiten erinnerungen von martin
wolf in seiner alten heimat neapel
feiern sie ihn heute abend zum letzten
mal keinen verehren sie wie ihn diesen
genialen fußballspieler der als mensch
mindestens genauso viel bar war wie sie
selbst noch vor zwei wochen hatten seine
fans in argentinien maradonas entlassung
aus dem krankenhaus gefeiert die gehirn
op nach blutgerinnsel china zu
überstehen
umso größer heute der schock über den
tödlichen herzinfarkt
ich habe meine frau 86 kennengelernt als
er dieses wm tor mit der hand gottes
erzielte für mich als poker fan und
argentinier ist er der größte überhaupt
sein tod ist unglaublich traurig
diego armando maradona auf dem rasen
einer der besten aller zeiten abseits
viel zu oft gestrauchelt aufgewachsen in
einem vorort von buenos aires bereits
mit 15 sein debüt in der ersten
argentinischen liga in italien gewinnt
er später mit neapel meisterschaft und
uefa-pokal und wird zum liebling der
tifosi zum weltstar avanciert er bei der
wm 86 mit seinem solo des jahrhunderts
gegen england
[Musik]
im selben spiel sein umstrittenster
treffer maradona spricht von der hand
gottes und wird später mit argentinien
weltmeister das privatleben des
superstars begleitet von skandalen 91
wird im kokain konsum nachgewiesen
anklagen wegen drogenhandels und
zuhälterei
es beginnt der abstieg mit
entziehungskuren gescheiterten comeback
versuchen und immer neuen skandalen
dennoch bleib diego armando maradona ein
nationales symbol argentiniens auch
deshalb ordnete die argentinische
regierung heute eine dreitägige
staatstrauer an
das war es von uns nach dem wetter geht
es wie schon gesagt mit dem deutschen
zukunftspreis weiter und wohl schmiese
hat um viertel vor eins er noch den
aktuellen stand im heute-journal update
was uns beide gibt es morgen wieder auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
gute million zuschauer morgen wird es
bei uns meist wieder trüb sein
der höchste luftdruck liegt ja schon
leicht östlich von uns mit diesem
hochdruckgebiet hier derzeit über ungarn
und deshalb kann eine kleine regenfront
von der nordsee jetzt norddeutschland
erreichen mit vielen wolken aber nur mit
ganz wenig regen sehr viel regen fällt
dagegen in portugal in spanien in
marokko auf den bergen schneit es dort
sogar ja bei uns was heute nacht wieder
neblig vor allen dingen im süden im
norden haben wir eher die bewölkung und
morgen früh beginnt es an der nordsee
leicht zu regnen an den küsten und im
nordwesten bleibt es dann mit etwa 3 bis
7 grad frostfrei sonst haben wir france
zwischen 0 und -6 grad und morgen wird
auf den bergen wieder am mildesten in
süddeutschland schwarzwald bis zu 13
grad sind möglich aber unten an der
donau bei nebel nur 0 bis 5 karte mit
dem frischen west wende norddeutschland
sind es dann dort sieben bis elf grad
ist es trüber norddeutschland immer
wieder regnet leicht das ist nur
sprühregen wahrscheinlich und dann kann
es auch mehr und mehr an der nordsee
auflockern auch über den mittelgebirgen
wird langsam heller die sonne kommt raus
vor allem dort eben auf den bergen und
in den niederungen an der donau am main
da bleibt es trüb aber vielleicht kommt
auch morgen wieder die sonne hier im
rheintal mal raus ja die aussichten es
ändert sich am freitag wenig aber dann
am wochenende wird aus austin kühler und
sonniger und jetzt schauen wir uns mal
die temperatur trend für berlin an
sie sehen also am wochenende
samstag/sonntag gehen die temperaturen
runter am montag auch noch dann pendeln
sie sich wahrscheinlich so maximal 25
grad 1 für berlin
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie es gut